tomorrow on CBS as part of the
festivities Candice who won earlier to
come on down with us and hang out and
Teresa is over there getting ready to
model for us are you excited to read
soon beyond all right everybody knows
that if I didn't smoke to dented to be a
Barker beauty but I love the Drew's okay
now let's find out what Candis is
playing for it's a cruise on Norwegian
Cruise Line
[Applause]
so if in give-up secret acts there's an
X hidden behind one of the question
marks could be the top could be in the
middle complete the bottom we don't know
that's for you to figure out I'm gonna
give you one free X here's your free X
Inc velcro that anywhere in any yellow
yellow square any yellow square just put
up a yellow square like you're playing I
have two more X's for you but you can
only get an X if you know the price of
the heated mug or the panini press is
that $80 or $120 drew I'm going to say
that's 120
I'm gonna change my answer 3:18 $80 $80
$80 the top let's go
no no small thing ok one more
it's the panini press $23 or $40 I'm
going to go with $23 sure corporate
stock I'm going to change my answer the
panini press is $40 no you can't put on
the question mark you that's what the
LoZ box is somewhere in here ok oh
you're going on a Norwegian cruise
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this